joining me my name is Heather Downing
I'm from Kansas City in the states and
this is my first time to Porto so before
you all leave if you're brave enough
please come up and tell me what I should
have been experiencing I'm very
interested in that
oh my goodness
what do you think this talk is about did
you read
do you know
I bet you do
so this talk is about what it's like to
be going from an individual contributor
to suddenly a manager because we all
know that you are brilliant and great
coders yes so the first thing we're
going to do is ask for more money which
everybody should ask for more money
so what happens when you ask for more
money they say great here's more money
and a promotion now you have a team of
16.
surprise
or maybe you put in for the same job
that your co-workers did so out of the
four of you you got it
now you have a mix of emotion right
you're like yes I get more money and
responsibility
but I was competing with my co-workers
so how are they going to feel about that
hmm
let's talk about this journey a little
bit
most of the problems that I've seen when
I went to go work for somebody at a any
company or even just as a consultant
was always running into
personal problems uh communicating with
somebody who had this exact path right
if only their company
invested in them learning how to treat
people hmm
so instead of waiting for your company
to do that let's just take control and
learn a little bit about this
so this is going to feel a little bit
like a TED talk if you've ever anybody
watched Ted ever yay so you're already
halfway there
so I'm going to use very fuzzy words
like
kindness and empathy
and on selflessness and reflection and
you're going to roll your eyes because I
did for many years until I realized that
the reason many people are leaving their
companies right now is not just pay it's
because they hate their manager
it's even worse when they used to be a
coder like you
right
so can we all agree that each one of you
are brilliant and you are on the way up
right and just give me a little bit of
your time and we'll talk about some
scientific ways to approach
personalities but also where people are
at in their career okay
good deal
so I want you to think back
to when you got to the top of your game
on any subject if you're very humble
like me and many others you will think
I'm not the topic in a game I don't know
what I'm doing.net just change for the
12th time right but you know that one
moment where you get in the Flow State
and things are just working and you only
had to build it once or twice and it
just worked and you you feel that
wonderful emotion right
but if you do that often enough you no
longer look at the ease in which you do
things you're looking for the problems
which is why you feel the problems more
acutely because you feel like I've been
doing this for a while and I should just
know what the answer is
that's how you know you're kind of up
there because you're actively looking
for problems
right you're in that wonderful Flow
State
but do you remember what it was like
when you began
can you really remember and I asked this
to a programmer of 25 years he's like I
have no idea how it was
because Tech has changed so much right
just in the past few years for me that I
can't imagine what it was like to face
challenges with something simple like a
console app to me I'm like oh I know how
that works did you in the beginning do
you remember what that was like
let's go back there if you can try okay
that frustration of figuring out A New
Concept without any context so you have
no idea what a console is first of all
and then you're being told okay just
make this magic eight ball app that just
magically works great
what do I do do I just start typing
now I'm again I'm taking you way back
right
do you remember the hours you would
spend trying to decipher what part of
programming really is from like the the
data science part from the algorithm do
I need to know algorithms do I need to
write algorithms turns out most of us
probably not we just need to use
algorithms in the right way right and
that blew my mind I was like you mean
I'm another layer on top of other
programmers that on top of other
programmers that go all the way down oh
that's pretty cool
but in the moment I thought I had to
know every single part of it
for every language for every application
right and so that stress of just not
really understanding but trying to go
forward anyway
you began to wonder if you had enough
space in your brain to figure it out at
least if you are like me I have severe
short-term memory loss so imagine trying
to cram for an exam doesn't work for me
because it takes time to transfer from
the short-term memory to the long-term
memory
just like a computer
I'm just buffering for a very long time
right so that means that the way I had
to work
was by reference so once I was allowed
to use Google more often I would Google
things and my own articles on stack
Overflow would pop up
like oh yeah that's how I did that has
anybody else done that we were searching
for something and you're like oh yeah I
figured that out two years ago okay cool
but you still feel like this and revisit
this emotion occasionally
now let's just say you finally did that
first app
and you feel like a wizard right the
first time I got that magic eight ball
app to work I showed freaking everybody
I'm like look look it does this thing
they're like yeah
so like no but like I wrote that like
from scratch I did it and they're like
okay
I have a calculator probably could do
something like that too
but you have that moment this is when
you were hooked and now you're a
programmer for life
right
so you're excited and you're like great
do I think that I can make money at this
you throw your hat in the ring and say
I'm a junior developer but I am willing
to learn and work in a team so they
throw you on a team because you're cheap
and they why not and they throw you in a
team and say okay now let's just start
coding
okay but remember your your various
levels of knowledge here and various
personalities did anybody tell you what
it was like to have to share pull
requests do you know anything about
these agile stand-up meetings and
everything nobody taught you that in
school did they nope they just said hey
this is how you make an app not telling
you that 80 of the other time is dealing
with all this other stuff
right so you get to find out at this
stage
you're thrown on you're clearly the
underdog in the team because everybody
else has already been there
so now you've had to figure out a
dynamic so this happens as early as the
first to second year
okay this is so crucial that most
dropouts now from Tech leave after the
second year because this is their first
experience
you meet all different kinds of
programmers uh all around you some
people are really friendly some people
are helpful some people just feel like
you're a threat or you're annoying
because they're busy you're trying to
actually do the work
okay
the sounding about right yeah
and it's not exclusive just to the
states I've sat in on many many
different team meetings all over the
world and it seems like the same
problems
uh is that suddenly you're just in it
and you have to help but you don't
you're not really that helpful
you're more of like a learning student
but then you become more of a mid-level
developer and certain things start
coming to you and you start providing
some value and and you know you thought
as you grow you would amass this amazing
knowledge right and everybody would come
to you as the all-knowing being but
you're just excited that you made fire
all right and so that and this right
here this moment is how you bond with
your teammates right you're like dude
did you see how this Library works so
much better than this other one
that's how I was with hashing algorithms
that's super nerdy you talk to me about
it later like did you know that it takes
this long to to crack this and this long
I was crazy right that's how we bonded
so now you're valuable but you do just
enough to you know maybe get yourself in
trouble
then you go through some real hardships
where you have shipped code that has
broken and it is your fault and you've
learned what not to do and so now you've
become this person who can sniff out the
trouble before it even hits the team
and you're feeling pretty good about
becoming a senior
right
now this is all internal I'm not saying
you're actually acting like this but
internally you're like hey I can see the
fire coming before the fire comes so you
should just take what I say and you're
feeling pretty good about this
and you should feel good about the
journey that you've taken
but remember success is a lousy teacher
it seduces smart people into thinking
they can't lose
right
I'll tell you what most people who have
built the systems that have recently
been hacked did not think that they were
being lazy about it they thought they
had a perfect system together
but
keeping this in mind because you are the
one on the team that did sniff that out
you seem like a big big thinker you know
like a high level thinker
tell you what let's get you promoted
great and you're excited because you
worked your ass off and you finally got
recognition and now your entire career
is changing so if you wanted to keep
coding I hate to break it to you
management probably isn't the latter you
want to go there are managers who still
code alongside their team members but
they're not as effective at holding all
of the bad things that are rolling
downhill because they're too busy
actually building with you to get things
out of the way for you it doesn't mean
that there aren't levels of it there's
definitely like senior developers
Architects lead developers but once
you're a manager and you are responsible
for the pay of your team this all
changes because now you have power that
is a lot bigger than just whether or not
you choose a good Library
are we in agreement on that
okay
I love this quote people buy into the
leader before they buy into the vision
and when you have an interview whether
you're the one giving it or receiving it
you make that decision in the first
three to four minutes yes they're longer
and if you go to Amazon it's like all
day and it's rounds and rounds of it but
really you make the decision in the
first three to four minutes based on how
they treat you
and if you're on the receiving end you
make that decision based on how much
they put you at ease that they believe
that you could be there
because why would you want to go to work
for somebody who's already giving off a
negative vibe or somebody who's very
demanding
not very many because it's not helpful
it's in the way that means whether or
not we're accepted is occupying part of
our subconscious instead of letting our
subconscious actually fix that algorithm
right so now it's always worried it's
always in a heightened state so that is
why you would turn down one interview
and not another based solely on your gut
feeling
that's where that comes from
but it's not your fault that you did so
well because you're awesome that you got
promoted right it's not your fault good
news is leadership is a muscle you can
build it clearly right now I have not
been building it but
I want to kind of accompany this with a
story of when it mattered
so I'm definitely not one of these
CrossFit people but I got really excited
about lifting weights and I said okay I
want to learn this because I want to
feel like Wonder Woman and I'm ready and
so we started this process and I was
gung-ho about two months into it I went
to my trainer and I was really
disappointed I said you know I am so
tired and sore I thought you said that
like the soreness would go away after a
few days but it like never does I'm
always sore is anybody else always sore
after they lift weights is it just me
and I said what's going on here it's
like come here let me show you something
so he took me into the secondary weight
room and he sat me down and he moved
some weights around and said okay go
ahead and lift this
so I do and he says was that taxing and
I said no what's the okay what are you
trying to say he's like I'm saying that
I never told you how much weight was on
the bar because it's not important it's
important that I see where you're
struggling and then as you grew in
strength I added more weight so when I
take it off and give this to you now
that is where you started two months ago
but you just didn't notice because
you've been building muscle this full
time
right that's why you've been sore
because if you as anybody here actually
led a team manage the team
you keep getting sore don't you there's
there's always more pain that comes
along but it's different now it's a
different pain it's not like the same
one because once you've learned that
muscle and how to deal with that
particular one then you can pivot and
deal with something else
so it can feel at first very
disheartening you're like nobody likes
me I've had two people quit on me I
can't ship this on time I feel like I
need to just code this myself and go in
there and you get very worn down very
quickly if you don't see what's
happening
it is muscle building and it does take
time and you probably won't notice
unless you kind of measure a little bit
about what you've conquered along the
way
sometimes you'll have really great
um very smart emotional people on your
team and they'll tell you how they need
to be treated but most of us aren't that
way we just hope that our boss is not an
you know and we don't tell them
how to live their life or what to do but
they want you to do that almost every
time like please tell me what what I can
do to make life easier because I don't
want to add more stress so that we don't
ship something on time yeah
but you've never had this job before
right so nobody told you that that's how
it's really going to be
I went and uh did a pretty big study
um that paper is coming out next year of
what developers want from the leaders
because I was so interested if what I
was experiencing was just me or if it
was more of a worldwide issue
and this is what I kind of discovered
distilled down
when you feel safe
the natural reaction is trust and can
and cooperation you if you feel safe you
you naturally want to go
paint to house or go do things together
because you don't have to worry about
the social anxiety aspect of that you
can just go conquer something
when we don't fear our leaders then
we'll combine our talents to face
challenges that come outside of the team
like
I don't know a salesperson telling us
something that is literally impossible
for us to do it's better for us to unite
and go well this is what we can give you
then worry about fighting amongst
ourselves and being a little afraid of
our leader
let's fix this problem and then we can
kind of go as a cohesive unit and
honestly slay all the dragons
they want good leaders that make them
feel safe is the number one feedback
that I got after polling literally
hundreds of developers all over the
place
another thing that was really specific
is that you need to feel safe to fail
so I have never felt this way because I
put myself at a high standard that
before I ship code I'm going to test it
and I'm going to make sure that it's not
going to fail I'm sure that the person
at Amazon that wrote just one line of
code and unfortunately erased a bunch of
data in a region really thought that
everything was good and he was setting
things up but the system was imperfect
it's not that the human isn't perfect we
already know that so why wouldn't you
put a system in place that allows people
to fail safely before we ship something
important
I cannot stress this enough you are not
infallible you are awesome because we've
all established that you're a brilliant
coder but you're not infallible and you
could be tired because you're too
obsessed with coding way more than you
should be and you will make
a keystroke that was a mistake it just
is happening so ask yourself if the
entire team was suddenly a junior
developers what would break if they if
they pushed something
and can you put anything in place that
would help them with that and can you
communicate that to your team because if
you do then they don't feel so worried
about trying new things out and trying
something that may or may not work
because they know that oh at least
they're not going to bring down the
whole company right
but also they need to feel safe to
confide in you and this is tough because
not everybody's a people person
sometimes I don't want to know about all
of the heavy things that are happening
at home for you but that's not what that
means
you are not their therapist there are
Professionals for that but what they
need to be able to confide in you is
something that you ask them to not share
with the team like I need time off I'm
grieving the loss of something it
doesn't need to be long you just need to
be able to keep that in confidence and
not share that with other team members
even if you're really frustrated
and this is violated a lot more than you
think so just keep that in mind that you
need to
make it very obvious that you know how
to keep confidence and keep that safe
they also wanted to at least from the
feedback I got was they want a leader
that actually has some vision
that's pretty tough I have no vision I'm
just trying to survive life man what
does that even mean you know I I don't
know
um what what I've distilled down after
working for some awesome leaders and
some bad ones over the years is that the
mission doesn't have to be crazy big it
just needs to be something as simple as
yes I know we are working on very boring
government software
but our mission can be that we will
always have really clean code here and
we'll find new ways to do this better or
that better and that's just our mission
of our team regardless of what project
we're working on and that can be
something that your team will get behind
is that you are a leader who's not just
I don't know I don't care to ship it you
care about the quality because of the
art of code because of the art of what
we're in
people will get behind that even if it
is a boring project so that's all we're
asking is find something that you find
really interesting about it that you
think can truly be more Mission bound
and people will follow you
they also want leaders that can Inspire
others to the calling and they're part
of it so instead of this is my singular
Vision I'm the Steve Jobs of everything
needs to go this way why not incorporate
some ideas that people have here's a
secret the less you've been in
development the more ideas you have
you have no because nobody's told you
it's impossible yet nobody's told you
that that is something that doesn't work
right so you're like well can we do
something like this that can could drop
like drones in that section and all of a
sudden everybody has this you know and
you're like well tell us more and maybe
maybe it just kind of jostles things up
enough to invigorate the team to have
them start thinking about things they
would like to do this is possible even
with the boring projects most of the
stuff I have done over the past decade
has been definitely things that most
people would not get out of bed for
but like they're important I guess I did
work on not important things like a
Snapchat filter but I'm just saying that
I've worked on things that it isn't
really even about that project it is
about the process and the different ways
in which we could approach it
this is totally possible regardless of
where you work so I don't want to hear
that oh you didn't get to work at a new
startup to get that feeling
most developers also would like you to
be flexible
um this is tough because you get no
flexibility from your boss
it's just this needs to happen here's
the deadline that we arbitrarily set but
here's the deadline just make it happen
go and you're like great so I have no
flexibility but I'm expected to be
flexible to all my devs
um
this puts you in a spot doesn't it
the reality is
the more pressure that people feel the
less likely they are to give quality
work
however if you're like me and you have a
brain that decides that it needs a
deadline in order to even activate
break it down into much smaller
deadlines for them and be like hey let's
just try this one thing and get
something done by the end of this week
because it will get everybody kind of
feeling good about one part of what
they're shipping
then it doesn't feel so overwhelming I
have a real issue with follow-through I
have my whole life because I get to the
hard stage and I'm like I need more time
for this and the deadlines here so I
just kind of throw my hands up I'm like
I don't know I need an expert to come in
and it often is not a difficult thing
it's just that I was given too much
information at once that I had to solve
okay so this is again something that you
can control right
this is one of my favorite
um ways of putting this if you have hard
times in your family would you consider
firing them
I mean maybe you would I don't know your
family's situation
but think twice about what is really
going on with your developers because if
they seem really abrasive or they don't
want to turn on their video on Zoom or
something like that uh you know
don't be so quick to judge the situation
you shouldn't sacrifice people to save
the numbers in the deadline just be like
oh not fast enough get out of the way
that is almost always the wrong choice
If you hired the wrong person okay
but this is everything going to fall
down if that one person doesn't deliver
really you got to look at your process
then
what is your bus factor is anybody
familiar with the bus Factor
okay a couple of you yeah just for those
who don't know a bus factor is
how many developers would it take for
this entire project to sync if they were
hit by a bus
so if you have a bus factor of one and
that's you that's bad that means nobody
under you actually knows how to hold
things up
um I believe in knowledge sharing not
knowledge hoarding like what Scott
hasman was talking about earlier and
that's so important in every stage of
your project that everybody needs at
least one other person who understands
what that module is doing okay so if you
have that that means that if you have
somebody who truly is not a good fit
the project won't fall on its face
because you still have at least one
other person that knows what's going on
in that aspect okay if you are a
contractor however and you are the sole
proprietor of your
company and you're the one delivering
that's rough right you don't have
anybody it's just you
this is the point where you renegotiate
your contract of how much time you need
and then you go ask the community you
should always have relationships outside
of your company that you work for or
your home business and that way I I have
people I can call the drop of hat and
say do you know how I would approach
this problem and they will always answer
if you don't have people like that in
your life take a look around the room
and I'm sure and just introduce yourself
later this is how it works this is how
it starts is that you find out what
somebody knows that is different from
what you know and that you can call on
so now I have like this little wheel of
people that I know are experts of this
or that even if they wouldn't admit it
that I could go and ask right
if you don't sacrifice the people to
save the numbers to save the deadline
they will notice and they will
reciprocate
because usually if you're at a
decently modern company you get to have
a review time
and now most companies ask your team how
is your manager will you review your
manager
that's really an intimidating thing to
say right but
you want that's where you get the real
feedback it's usually anonymous because
you don't know which person said what's
that's where you get the real feedback
about what you're doing and if you
held off all the heavy weight that was
much higher in the hierarchy from you
away from your team they see that if you
took all of the boring meetings so they
could actually code they see that they
know
they know
a technical leader will and I'm going to
list all these out for you
listen respect encourage recognize and
Empower now don't you feel like you're
at a TED Talk
and don't worry I'm not going to give
you arbitrary words I'm going to tell
you what they mean a leader doesn't need
to have the first word the last word or
even most of the words this is great for
us introverts right we that means we
don't have to do a lot of the talking as
a manager we can allow our team to do
that the state of a team will often be
made clear to you when you listen and
guide us what they're saying
individually
most often you're going to be the one
who has to work out communication issues
but remember you weren't sent to
management training right because you're
This brilliant coder so what do you know
about communication besides what you do
when you talk to a computer
right
that means that now your job has shifted
forever I would argue that without a
leader like this every Dev team falls
apart I don't care how good they are
individually without this person
they fall apart
but that means you may have to leave the
coding behind
sacrifice for the greater good
you could still dip your toes in it and
know what's going on but don't get in
the way of letting people on your team
be the ones who really Blossom and
flourish and Thrive don't be there to
show off I know it's really tempting
because you like code that's why you
started this but now your job is to
listen to the ideas listen to the
complaints and listen for the moments
where people kind of want to shine they
kind of want to try something okay
always let an employee go first on a
one-in-one reading you know what a
one-on-one meeting is yes no oh half of
you do not hmm
you got a management problem
it's one of the most important things
ever uh to have that
um I didn't realize how important they
were until I wasn't given any
when I worked for somebody
so after what I mean by listen is that
you need to process what they said and
if an action is required
then do it last
sometimes we just need to vent
please let us do that
please let us dismant and then at the
end go is there is there something that
you would suggest that you would like
done
before I make suggestions because
oftentimes your suggestion might be a
little too much like too too quick too
hard to anything maybe they do know what
they want sometimes they don't
if it's a heavy subject and it sounds
like maybe they need therapy remember
you are not a clinical psychologist so
you need to let the professionals do
their job but let them know that hey
maybe this is something that you can
pursue if you need extra time off to
pursue that please do that and that is
about as supportive as you need to be
you don't need to diagnose what's going
on okay
demonstrate active listening by
repeating what you heard so they have an
opportunity to correct it if it was
misunderstood okay
uh respect
this believe it or not was the hardest
one for me
don't respect people who are jerks
because it's a choice
you don't have to be that way but you're
choosing to be that way I don't believe
just take me as I am this is just the
way I am no
that's not how it works
you weren't born a jerk you just decided
to be and so I have a hard time
respecting people that are but
I had to dig deep down because they are
this way for a reason and the jerk that
you work with which is either your boss
or your co-worker and everybody has
worked with one of these people
is an opportunity for you to realize
that everybody has different
communicational needs
okay this is this is when my
um real obsession with the scientific
ways that the human the humans in Iraq
started because I'm like what is what is
this person getting out of this Behavior
this this statement this action why
would he why would they be a bully why
would they be a jerk
what I discovered is they're oftentimes
very insecure and when they're insecure
they have to Puff themselves up and make
themselves feel better by putting you
down this is very cliche and yet it
happens anyway like we know about it if
we do it anyway kind of like I know I
should eat less calories to lose weight
but I do it anyway
you know that's we know about these
things right so what do you do with that
person
this one was very difficult and it may
not be you might have a great team but
then you hire the one person who will
not stop talking about the ways that
they believe things should be done
and it's okay that they have that
excitement it's not okay that they tell
everybody else that their idea sucks and
they're wrong now they're just a jerk
and they're just standing in the way but
you're the leader that means you can't
just let things happen and let somebody
who is poisonous to the team like infect
the rest of them because then they're
going to leave because you do nothing
everybody's leaving
what do you do now you're stuck between
a rock and a hard place and what's even
worse is the jerk is usually a good
coder
right they usually are they usually are
because they know they are because they
know that they're decent at their job
and they don't need to apologize for any
to anybody for the way they are okay
unfortunately now they're undermining
the entire team atmosphere so what do
you do you say um please don't be a jerk
and they're like I'm not a jerk
no I'm just saying it like it is I'm
just being real I'm just giving you the
truth
all right I'm just giving you the truth
oh
so how do we how do we start off with
respect when they don't respect you
because you you feel that really early
especially if they were one who missed
out on that promotion and you got it
you know how do you build this
start with respecting the differences
that you have instead of the temptation
of telling them that they're wrong I
know this is hard I I didn't believe
this either I'm like I'm Gonna Be The
Virtuous one who's saying you are being
not nice
and they were going to just be like oh
I'm so sorry uh uh yeah I will never
happen again
that's not how it usually goes
right
so I had to start respecting what they
brought to the table and in this case I
was working on a mobile project and they
were brilliant Android developer
brilliant and I got to be put in lead on
lead on the project
but I was a xamarin developer so I
wasn't as cool as the down to the metal
Android developer was you know
there's a whole thing so then I decided
to acknowledge how much more he must
know about some of the ux changes that
came through for Android
Etc and you know I would really like
your help looking over some of this
stuff because what I did is I gave him
that yes I instilled that yes I did have
confidence in him
and then once the walls were down then I
could be like hey you know it would be
pretty cool if you could Mentor this
other person
they usually just want a chance to flex
how much they know
right but you are measured as a mentor
by how much the person grows and if the
person isn't growing they'll be like oh
they just don't get it
oh maybe you can change the way you you
talk to them and maybe they just have a
different way of learning
that was the most effective thing I
could have done because then he had to
learn that there was more than just
Hands-On
um pair programming that could be done
this person was very introverted and
needed to just like read and digest and
go home and do some coding on their own
and then bring back the solution for the
pull request okay so once they figured
that out he mellowed a lot towards
everybody else because he when he had
assumed that this person was just stupid
and they couldn't grasp what they were
doing it really was that he wasn't
communicating effectively and so it kind
of took care of itself once he realized
oh
they're not stupid they just needed a
different way to look at the problem
that's a good way to not say you're just
a jerk fix your attitude because nobody
wants to hear that
nobody wants to hear that
and not everyone's a natural-born
cheerleader and I acknowledge that
um I remember talking to some people in
Sweden about
um how Americans are viewed as just
everything's amazing and we're all so
excited right we can't help us our
culture right and I but I genuinely am
that way all the time right I'm just
like yay I'm excited but I'm also
terrified when things go wrong so like
big extremes
um
and uh it's okay you don't have to be a
cheerleader you don't have to be like oh
my God that was an amazing pull request
I'd be fine you don't need to do that I
promise it doesn't need to be fake that
is what I want to come across I'm
genuinely very enthusiastic and I
hopefully it comes through that it's
really me but you don't have to suddenly
switch your demeanor to being like this
encourager okay being a successful
encourager means believing in the
ability that the developer has to
overcome
especially when they don't believe it
themselves
what you say holds so much weight they
go and talk to their friends on Twitch
about it they talk to them like oh yeah
my managers did this today I'm sure
you've done that yeah well yeah I guess
I guess we were doing this thing and it
didn't go well and uh so every word you
say holds a lot of weight you don't have
to go over the top to encourage at all
you have to see the potential though in
the person and share it with them often
in order for them to push through the
hard stuff and make it feel worth it
when a study was done on what actually
mattered to any employee compensation
was like number three
the first one
was whether or not they were even
recognized
and it is so cheap and easy to do if you
have to set yourself an alarm a calendar
reminder whatever that I haven't said
something nice about what you know Denny
has done today or in the past month then
maybe I should pay more attention and
look for something genuine
to recognize and call out
I didn't think this actually worked
until I started doing it and then when
they would leave I asked them later you
know what was your
um most positive memory
um here at the company because you if
they live on good terms and it was
always man I loved that I was able to do
something that mattered and the only
reason they know that something mattered
is because we told them that it mattered
we all kind of want that right
there's a lot more easy jobs you could
have
than this so if you slave away and you
ship something in you hear nothing about
it
what even if it's small that always
irked me especially when you make fixes
like super fast and it's like a Friday
at like six or seven p.m and you really
wanted to go and spend time with your
family but you're like oh this this one
thing is misspelled here I'll just do a
quick PR and I'll I'll push it and you
nobody said anything nobody gave you a
thank you nobody did any of it
and it's a little rough
so your job now is to pay attention to
the small stuff and say hey thanks for
doing that it can be a quick slack
message it could be you don't have to
make an email if you're in person which
not a lot of us are but if you're in
person with your team you can obviously
obviously just walk by their desk and
say oh hey thanks for getting that out
the other day you didn't you didn't have
to do that I'm not saying that you have
to work 60 hours a week but thank you
for doing that that was really nice and
that makes a huge impact suddenly that
probably lasts them another couple
months like oh I guess I'm good I guess
I'm not gonna get fired today yeah
that's good right
it doesn't take a lot so dig deep and
even if it's the challenging person who
seems to get everything wrong I bet you
they got something right
where you weren't paying attention
we spend on average as much time with
our co-workers as our family that blows
me away
so it can be pretty exhausting if you
don't feel that your effort is
appreciated
I went through that recently actually
when I before I left the company before
as I didn't feel like I got any feedback
I even asked for it I'm like
am I helpful they're like oh yeah yeah
you're fine oh
when you put so much of yourself and we
naturally do this in Tech you put so
much yourself into something and it's
fine oh that sucks
you want it to be really good you want
it to be appreciated if you're American
like me you want it to be awesome
you know and if it's not even though yes
you did technically check every box you
want to know how to make it better how
do you make it to where it is
that chapter and that is usually the
seed by the way of somebody who could be
a budding architect or somebody who
could grow even more in their career is
when they're like yeah this is great but
like I want to do a little more
please give the opportunity for the
coders in your group
to talk to you about that and if you
have no idea how they could do it better
open it up to the group this is really
good how would you do this that's even
more efficient that's my favorite word
more efficiently
um I never paid attention to Performance
because my framework did it for me and
then I was like oh but if we have very
slow internet down in Australia
how can we make this more performant
right
technically it works but like how can we
make it better and that also allows your
team to bond because now they can throw
ideas around with each other and if they
don't know then everybody's
going online and checking out all the
different options
delegation is really key so empowering
is probably uh the hardest thing for
somebody like you or like me who has
worked really hard to get where they are
because you can only control yourself
right you can't really control the
emotions or the actions of others so
empowering somebody feels like you're
giving away a really important aspect to
your job
um
but delegating is the right thing to do
it's painful for me
but it's the right thing to do every
person will have a different level of
confidence here too
so
many people need continuous reminders
that they have permission to just go
make a decision without you
remember if you Empower your team right
you can actually have a vacation
that doesn't mean you need to not do
your job it means that enough people
remember that bus Factor enough people
need to know what to do and feel like
they can do it without getting yelled at
and just go do the thing one good
example is I don't want to be the one to
do all your travel please just book
yourself and then just submit it an owl
as long as it's not like over five
thousand dollars I'll probably that's an
example of one way that you can just
diverse divorce yourself from the huge
email threads and huge said you get on
slack right that's easy
and if there is an exception then you
deal with it and you take it
and you just give feedback I mean it's
it's so much better to delegate some of
the more important responsibilities to
your team but it's important to not
delegate and walk away and never check
back in
how will they know if they're doing it
right
you never talk to them about it you just
like oh great thanks for like doing my
job and your job appreciate it has
anybody done their job plus their
manager's job
just me oh you guys have good managers
yeah sometimes it feels like they're not
doing anything
like your manager isn't doing anything
and I never wanted to be that so I
overcompensated and I was like I'm gonna
be like the leader that leads from the
side and we're going to cut together
it's gonna be great uh when you do that
you will gravitate towards one or two
people on your team and not the others
because you'll find somebody who's
coding style you're compatible with
foreign
so
you gotta think about this a little bit
how heavy
is the one who wears the crown like
suddenly it is heavy and it is a big
responsibility but you have to decide
why you're doing this step
and
the worst thing that you can do is take
this step
without considering what you will do to
other people you're responsible now for
their salary and for whether or not they
have a good quality of life at work
not your company don't blame oh our
policies ah I can't do anything about it
you can make a very safe bubble for your
team you absolutely can you can control
a lot more than you think you can and
what's even better is that most people
above you are not as technical as you so
when you say it's probably can't be done
what are they going to say oh yeah we
know it can be done no you're the one
who is the technical expert and you're
the one who has the team
don't be afraid to protect your team
which means you have to care about them
at all
and if it makes you feel icky it's okay
there are other individual contributor
paths where you can still do all of the
coding you wanted to do and become like
a fellow at a very high level
if it makes you feel icky to have to
deal with people's emotions and the
bottom line don't become a manager it's
not worth the twenty thousand dollar pay
raise you got I'm just saying it's not
but if you do this right
you are so influential as to whether or
not people stay in this industry I can't
even tell you
a good manager will help catapult a
career for a developer and it leaves a
lasting impression for four to five
years
how cool would it be that you got to be
part of that that you got to help
Empower them instead of losing people in
drugs
I'm not saying the programming is for
everybody but
I think it's for most people
I think it's for most people and it's
okay if you disagree
none of us were born coding if you were
I'd love to meet your mom
but none of us were born this way so
this is something we had to learn and I
think it is possible to be really good
at it even if you didn't come from a
technical background in a family
that brings us to the care so how do you
take care of your Junior Developers
well think of if you think back to it
um how how would you demonstrate things
to your kids
or how did you get demonstrated to when
you were a kid
if you have to show them first how to do
the tasks don't talk in big words and
say uh we need to deliver this thing and
that thing and they're like what is that
thing they need to be free to say what
is that thing and you need to show them
physically on a keyboard this is what I
mean and this is where you would go for
more information about that thing and
here is the end result described
lay it out lay a nice pathway out and if
they can follow that remember they don't
have the muscle memory yet of where to
go look for stuff it's not obvious that
you go to stack Overflow sometimes I
don't even go there anymore I go other
places but
it's not always obvious where to go
right so show them that
let them make mistakes and remind them
that it happens it happens all of us we
all like War Stories right oh yeah that
happened to me when I started to don't
worry about it please share that
because they're already nervous as heck
that they finally got a paying job and
and now they're worried about screwing
up okay just encourage them to get up
and try it again and not okay well
clearly this isn't your area so
go away and we'll have this other person
who knows what they're doing do it
please don't do that
have this person come over and ask them
questions about what they didn't
understand
not let me show you how it's really done
no ask some questions about what part of
that process they didn't get and then do
it at Target because it allows two
things one it allows this developer to
learn how to communicate
and secondly it allows this developer to
feel like well they didn't get all of it
wrong they got part of it wrong
which is a confidence Builder okay
so how would you take care of them once
they're mid-level Developers
this is where co-worker pairing is
really supportive you need to support
that people are doing things together I
hate this one
I am not a good pair programmer I get
very intimidated and I feel like
everybody's judging me and it's eight
hours of it and I just can't do that for
eight hours I need to just go away and
then come back with it but it doesn't
have to be an intense pairing session
that's what we're talking about what
they mean is hey you two figure out how
to do this thing
okay together however way you want to
work figure it out together and you both
present something that you both looked
at right do more of those suggestions
instead of people being out on a silo by
themselves which I like but it isn't
conducive to the bus Factor
because that means only I know about it
and then I get hit by a bus and then
there's nothing delivered so please this
is the part where you encourage your mid
developers to deliver things together at
least two people
and now encourage them to contribute
more to projects
you generate a lot of confidence in your
mid-level developers by encouraging them
to vocalize vocalize their ideas and ask
them what they think first so do you
have a stand-up has anybody done a
stand-up or where you all report what
your progress is in the day in the
morning okay
um don't let your seniors start don't
let your architect start the most junior
level to the mid to level developer and
up because
it teaches them to have the confidence
to speak first
and they may have ideas
that you didn't think of because of this
I'm really comfy in this.net bubble I've
been in for 10 years I'm not really
comfy talking about react but
clearly someone else is then maybe
they'll bring up a different way of
approaching a problem than I would I
want to reach into my comfort bubble
I've worked hard for it to be here you
know I want to to do apis this way I
don't want to do it that way
but maybe that would be a better option
so if you do it lease experience to most
experienced you will see how fast your
mid-level developers become your seniors
because they're able to not have to
speak against somebody with more
experience than them they're able to
just start from there and it really
humbles your senior developers to listen
to How smart
the people that are more Junior to them
really are because they're actually
given the space to talk about what's
going on
so how do you take care of these senior
developers you know what you used to be
before you were a manager
you will feel a natural kinship to
senior Developers
it won't be natural because you get it
you both went through lots of different
scenarios in Tech so you'll probably
naturally be able to talk about more
things
the way you take care of these people is
to allow time for individual
experimentation
and autonomous tasks
that's where they feel they get to get
in that flow State remember that first
slide where he got to really think and
just let it flow it's hard to flow if
all you're ever doing
is mentoring please give them the gift
of doing some autonomous tasks where
they get to be creative and they get to
have that flow State because that's
really what we want right I think that's
so cool when you get in that that moment
where you get everything flowing
together but ask them to bring new ideas
to the team
because they're the ones who have really
thought about it the most right and
explain why not just because I've
thought of it
explain why and show visually why if you
that means you are training this person
to be able to communicate very highly
like what you do
once you get to this level that means
they can talk to anybody not just other
seniors they can talk to much more
Junior people than them and that means
they could also talk to people who are
not in Tech about what's going on
because they're able to step down the
ladder of difficulty
so let's talk about personalities
that we kind of understand what to do
now that we've walked through for each
career path part of the career path but
now we each have individual
personalities that we're throwing in
there
so how do you feed an introvert
oh man
this one was difficult because
we are very attracted to this particular
type of field because we don't have to
go be in customer service right and so
we do this but
what's necessary to realize is these are
the people who will get burnt out so
fast from meeting after meeting after
meeting after meeting
it takes energy to log on and talk to
people or have them in their in whether
it's in person or online and if you do
that they will have nothing left in the
tank to even like work on stuff because
they're exhausted just from the
person-to-person interaction all the
time
so be mindful of those people who are
introverted and all I would say is that
yes we all need to get together but be
respectful of time
and you want to you know make be
supportive of however they can produce
their best work right but if it takes a
lot of energy to do to be in meetings 80
of the time that's probably not
conducive so be mindful of their how
quickly their energy goes away that they
have to muster to deal with others
how do you feed an extrovert
they're the most fun aren't they they're
just so bubbly and out there and they're
the first ones who will
volunteer for things you know they're
also the ones like yeah we need a team
outing together let's do the thing and
they're great they're a little
overwhelming for some people but what's
good about them is that they will bring
the morale of your team up
they'll bring it way up so it's good to
recognize even if you're not one of
those people what they can bring to the
table
but what the introvert brings to the
table is interesting these are the most
reflective people these are the ones who
will go into another room for a while
think about it and then bring back this
basket of profound thought about the
problem because they haven't had to deal
with just the person interaction they've
been able to really deeply think about
the problem so you see both of these
people
from a personality standpoint do bring
something to your team even if they're
not like you
so how do you feed an optimist we all
know these people
oh we use this Library it's going to be
amazing it's great solving all your
problems it's gonna be great
what they need to thrive is they need a
shot at hope you need to say that things
are not abysmal you need to at least let
them look and examine a new way so that
there's hope again okay that's what they
need
but as much as we need an optimist
somewhere on the team man do we need the
pessimist
the pessimists I've met a lot more of
them in their senior years than in their
junior years
but what they bring to the team is very
easy to describe
The Optimist brings let's do this great
new framework let's do this great new
whatever and they're the ones saying
right so how many stars on GitHub does
that have right so um who's going to be
maintaining that code or are they just
going to yank it from us and all of a
sudden nothing works in the future right
they're the ones who checked The
Optimist on reality
at sometimes as a manager this person
can feel very challenging for you
because they're always down they're
always you know negative but they they
do bring that check and balance to the
rest of the team and that's your
opportunity to acknowledge
that you appreciate that they keep the
team in check
what do we do about sensitive folks oh
that could be a lot of us right
sensitive people are are rough because
they can feel the entire morale of the
team they're the ones the most plugged
into probably what's happening they feel
things are off with the sales department
or another co-worker
they're just very
again plugged into to The Human Side so
this is a great opportunity for you to
talk to them about how they feel things
should go for everybody because they're
more likely to be selfless than selfish
do you feed a bold person do you even
need to feed them I mean I feel like
they just
are born excited about life bold people
are are really hard for me
because they can be bold and unkind
right they can be unkind some people are
really bold and they're kind and they're
they're great we love those people but
they can be unkind too how do you feed
somebody like that I'll tell you what
the it gets worse if you just keep a lid
on them and tell them to be quiet and
and not and go in the corner you need to
be giving them things that they can
maybe present to other departments in
your in your company
like hey why don't you tell people what
the road map is for all of our Dev
releases and they're like yes I'm on
that and they'll put it together and
they're they're and they will feel very
fulfilled but you've got to give them a
chance to channel the boldness somewhere
sometimes the boldness is hey you know I
volunteer to find another way to do
something can I present it they're
usually the ones who want to present
stuff
foreign
individual that is you can tell they're
really smart they may not have all the
knowledge yet you can you know you know
probably in a few minutes talking to
somebody in a hurry you wow they seem to
really like dream big and they they seem
to have a lot of ideas
they just need to probably pair with
somebody that has any sort of influence
over your product whatsoever so that
means they can think outside of what is
currently possible and they can
take you to the next level with stuff
okay there are many developers that fall
into this category but they're they
don't necessarily they're not bold but
they're just quiet dreamers and they
really are the ones who say hey maybe we
could return the rocket to Earth
backwards instead of just throwing it
away of the ocean
you know
which leads me to the last one which is
not a personality
this is something that can happen to any
one of us we can go through a lot of
stress we can go through a lot of
tragedy or we could just be burnt out as
a developer
down-hearted people have a really hard
time showing up and giving their best
self but you see them want to try and
you see that they are trying but it's
just they're very aware that they suck
and they're terrible and they just know
right this is the moment where you give
them the space to go talk to somebody
about these things don't go judging them
just be like hey I noticed that you
don't seem very happy in what you're
doing
I'm not happy and make sure you
immediately follow up with there's many
times in this profession that I have
been burnt out or I have whatever
let me give you the space just to go
figure out for a little while you don't
need to diagnose them you don't need to
be any of that you just need to be
quietly supportive
disconnected people are the worst
over the past several years that's how I
felt I was very disconnected from
everybody I felt very much individual
and not part of a team
but if you follow kind of the steps that
I've outlined here I'm far from an
expert but this is something that I've
learned if you just start with this deck
and I'll definitely post it for y'all
and learn how to treat your team as a
whole
you're going to be a lot more successful
with reuniting disconnected teams
whether you have the opportunity to do
it in person or not
as a manager I can tell you this
demanding that your team not be remote
is a mistake
it doesn't mean you can't have mandatory
team outings where you all get together
that's fine but
if you say no we have to be in person
because I feel like I don't have control
when they are remote
is more of an insecurity inside of you
than in a vulnerability in your team
it's an opportunity for you to fix a lot
of the way you communicate I've been in
a remote first team for three years it's
been the best experience
it means that nobody is left out of a
conversation because we think online
first and if we're in person great
so I will say this and now I'm running
out of a little bit of time here and I
will post this
I'm going to close with one of my good
friends best quotes
trust your team's judgment you may need
to step in to make decisions and
priority calls but this will be on the
information provided by your team if you
get this right you should have a good
autonomous and self-directed team
thank you for spending time with me
today if you have any questions let me
know
but good luck on your promotion
thank you
foreign